is this what an SUV looks like Mercedes
thinks it ought to the GLA is a new
addition to mercedes family of white
off-road vehicles it comes in an
all-wheel version and his mercedes first
SUV with a new 4matic drives fully
variable power distribution but as the
same platform as the a-series its
competitors outies q3 and BMWs x1 are
already established on the market
purchased driver robert's antique says
the Geo a success will depend on
high-volume sales but small SUVs are in
demand all over the world and in the
premium segment customers are willing to
pay high prices then you couldn't all
behide the GLA starts at 29,000 300
euros in Germany about 1600 euros more
than the comparable a series car the two
have the same wheelbase the GLA zenk
makes it 12 and a half centimetres
longer
it's also six centimeters taller than
the a-series vehicle and that results in
two centimeters more Headroom in the
backseat
you cannot artist driver says the GLA
speedy appearance means you sit lower
than in other SUVs of its class though
still higher than the a series but the
air drag coefficient of 0.29 is the best
in its class and substantially
contributes to the GLA slow fuel
consumption second on football to scale
by all the engines have the start/stop
function and meet the euro-6 emissions
norm we tested the GLA with the 250
4matic engine which produces 155
kilowatts it Sprint's from zero to 100
kilometers an hour in 7.1 seconds
clocks at top speed of 230 kilometers an
hour and shifts with a seven-year double
clutch transmission it costs about
thirty seven thousand five hundred euros
in Germany the gles interior is more
like a luxury sedan than a robust
off-road vehicle with this compact SUV
Mercedes is targeting a young affluent
clientele the buttons on the central
console are tidally arranged above them
are three round vents as in all mercedes
compact models
but how well does the Geo a handle
off-road use we left the pavement to
seek adventure
an optical underwriter and dark gray
recessed cladding all around to
underscore that the GLA is an SUV and
protect the paint from flying grit but
what's really special about the GLA is
its aerodynamics the underbody is
covered to prevent air turbulence
especially in speeds above 60 kilometers
an hour this reduces fuel consumption
noticeably
we see that as an indication that the
goe is at home primarily on the pavement
but a little ride on a dirt track has
its pleasures
all floated off McConnell Robert says
the GLA which is based on the a series
won't perform miracles off-road but
handles terrain better than its
appearance might suggest it steers like
a sedan if you leave out the off-road
package the car moves safely and
smoothly through curves with the feel of
a compact rather than an SUV the GLA is
for those who want to sit higher than in
the a-series
appreciate a jaunty appearance and
accept a hefty price list this medium
gear are good petite